[Musik]
hallo
meine sehr verehrten
ich bin krank und das hat man jetzt
gerade schon den ersten Wörtern gemerkt
meine Damen und Herren das hält uns
allerdings nicht davon ab hier in der
heutigen Folge Skyblock mit Luca mal
ordentlich ich weiß gar nicht was er da
oben suchen hat mal ordentlich die
Monster fahren zu Reparieren von daher
tatsächlich direkt mal eben fix und
timelapse wie ich hier Steiner Bau aber
das hat mir glaube ich in der letzten
Folge schon als Problem dass dann äh die
uns immer näher kam von daher werde ich
uns erstmal hier so einen kleinen
Schutzwall bauen zack zack das uns
hoffentlich niemand abschießt während
wir jetzt hier Koblenz haben also ganz
fix bei eben schnell schon meine
timelaps
[Musik]
so meine Damen und Herren ich habe jetzt
gerade mal erstmal so viel Cobblestone
geholt wie ich glaube dass wir benötigen
um hier unsere Taktik so ein bisschen
umzusetzen denn mir wurde ziemlich
häufig das hier unten in die Kommentare
geschrieben unter dem letzten Video nee
das ist die falsche Ebene ich muss mich
ein weiter runter bauen hierhin und das
keine Monster spawnen wenn ich zurück
laufe ähm ja ihr habt ja gerade schon
eingeblendet gesehen mir wurde häufig in
die Kommentare geschrieben Luca Bau dich
von der Seite an deinen Fallturm ran und
äh Bau dann so eine kleine Brücke da
rein sodass nichts spawnt und dann
schlussendlich kannst du die ganzen
Monster Alter mir wieder den
Grafikfehler ähm dann schlussendlich
kannst du die ganzen Monster die unten
sind mit deinem Pfeil und Bogen aus der
sicheren Entfernung töten so dass du
nicht abgeschossen wirst ach guck mal
hier sind wir schon genau und ähm dann
haben wir tatsächlich einfach die
Möglichkeit alles mal zu reparieren und
müssen dann nachher einfach nur diese
Plattform wieder abbauen also wieder
unten sehen mich auf jeden Fall ich
hoffe jetzt einfach nur dass mich kein
Skelette irgendwie abschießt hat aber
bisher alles ganz gut geklappt ich werde
jetzt einfach mal hier vorne das ganze
offenbauen
oh mein Gott
so da staut sich jetzt da an und jetzt
haben wir die Möglichkeit da unten alles
zu töten mit unseren Pfeilen von hier
oben
wir haben
das meiste da unten sollte weg sein ich
laufe jetzt mal wieder zurück und werde
mich jetzt hier vorne direkt unseren
Turm lang wieder runter bauen ich hätte
natürlich auch im Wasser einmal
mitnehmen können und ich dachte mir wenn
ich hier runtergeschossen werde wäre das
ein bisschen zu risky wenn ich ein
Wassereimer in der Hand hätte aber jetzt
muss ich hier einzelne
[Musik]
ja ich wollte eigentlich ins Wasser
springen aber gut ich mache mir mal eben
fix noch mal eben neues Schwert so dass
wir uns hier vorne entspannt in den
Kampf bewegen können jetzt müssen wir
nur aufpassen dass da vorne kein Creeper
noch irgendwie chillt weil ich glaube
das wird tatsächlich doch die Creeper
haben wir alle getötet jetzt kommen nur
noch die anderen hier an die müssen wir
jetzt noch eben alle töten die sind aber
alle one hit das Hühnchen bleibt einfach
mal hier da können wir ja glaube ich
Samen einfach in die Hand nehmen so dass
es mitkommt das müssten aber dann mal
ganz kurz noch mal eben abchecken denn
wenn jetzt gleich wieder Nacht wird und
hier neue Sachen spawnen dann müssen wir
auf jeden Fall durch sein mit unserer
komischen Aktion hier wieder nehmen war
also mal eben kurz Weizenkörner locken
das Hühnchen an und wir haben
tatsächlich ein Tier ich weiß also wo
kann denn das herkommen können wir das
mal unten in die Kommentare schreiben
der Kleine wird auf jeden Fall erstmal
hier schön in Sicherheit gebracht wir
gehen hier vorne zu unserem was ist denn
das
das ist glaube ich der krüppelste
Fichtenbaum den ich je gesehen habe
[Applaus]
ich habe mich im Regen die Tage draußen
angesteckt ne
und jetzt regnet es ja auch noch in
Minecraft ich kann da wirklich kotzen
ich sprinte jetzt allerdings mal ganz
fix hier rüber und repariere eben
schnell die monsterfarben genügend
fichtenzäune habe ich gerade noch in
meiner Kiste gefunden Fackeln habe ich
in der anderen Hand das heißt wenn ich
jetzt die 60 drauf drücke sollte das
auch klappen hier vorne auch Zack und
jetzt können wir hier da brauchen wir
noch ein bisschen mehr bruchsteine für
das heißt da muss ich noch mal eben ein
paar abbauen gehen und dann sollten wir
tatsächlich auch genügend haben um hier
alles wieder auszubessern also zack zack
zack und hier vorne zack zack dann hier
vorne natürlich die Fläche drauf und
dann hat man natürlich außen rum noch
die Bruchstein Stufen und das äh die uns
eigentlich sehen aber irgendwie
explodiert aber glaube ich daran weil
ich die mit einer Axt geschlagen habe
und nicht mit dem schweren Lachse der
dauert immer ein bisschen länger bis das
schlägt und dann ist er irgendwie
explodiert also müssen echt ein bisschen
schneller seine Zukunft ich ähm wer hat
mich jetzt
ey dass die hier
immer wieder ankommen ich bin doch
wirklich das zeigt uns allerdings meine
Damen und Herren das wir vernünftiges
Essen brauchen von daher werde ich jetzt
einfach mal das ganze Bohnen mir was wir
tatsächlich gesammelt haben durch die
ganzen Skelette die wir getötet haben
das nutze ich jetzt einfach mal um hier
vorne einfach mal so ein bisschen
illegal also es ist nicht illegal aber
ist natürlich schon nicht so richtig
dass ich das jetzt hier wachsen lassen
glaube ich ähm ich doch ich hatte meine
Tomatenpflanze stimmt die wurde mir zum
Einzug geschenkt meine Wohnung in
Hamburg die ist aber irgendwie nach
einem Monat ist sie dann auch irgendwie
gestorben naja ich lass mir jetzt auf
jeden Fall erstmal künstliche so ein
bisschen Weizen wachsen denn aus Weizen
das weiß natürlich jeder Mann können wir
uns also Hühnchen können wir uns hier
vorne direkt neue Brot machen haben dann
hier acht Brote und äh brauchen
allerdings insgesamt zehn für eine neue
Challenge die zehn Brote besagt
nach oben
Wecker
zehnte wenn ich jetzt eins esse seht ihr
schon und meine hungerleiste die
beginneriert sich komplett voll jetzt
einfach
so
danke
ich war ja meinem früheren Leben
Scharfschütze irgendwie süß dass wir
jetzt hier so einen kleinen Freund ne
wie heißt du ach gott bleibt mir
gestohlen okay ähm wir müssen uns darum
kümmern dass wir die Monster fahren
jetzt hier so ein bisschen wieder auf
Vordermann kriegen von der muss sich
erstmal ganz kurz wieder kommen
[Musik]
so Freunde ich habe jetzt gerade mal
ordentlich
Bruchsteine abgebaut dass meine
Spitzhacke wieder kaputt gegangen ist
und ich habe auch ein bisschen eine neue
Ordnung gemacht und zwar habe ich hier
vorne letzte Kiste hingestellt mit allen
natürlichen Sachen Natur
related Zeugs dann habe ich die Kids
jetzt erstmal so für den ganzen
Krimskram sehen von der Monsterfarm
kriegen da hatten wir auch irgendwie
eine eisenschaufel plötzlich am Start
keine Ahnung warum hier vorne habe ich
noch Holzkiste gemacht und hier eine
Steinkiste ich glaube das ist ein
bisschen besser die Ordnung und jetzt
werden wir uns hier vorne daneben
einfach mal hoch bauen es kam
zwischendurch ja gerade auch noch so ein
paar ja von diesem Phantom rüber
geflogen leider die Sporen anscheinend
jetzt häufiger oder auch bei Regen ich
weiß nicht warum genau
ich hatte so viel Freunde heute
ich hatte noch vor auch wenn ich krank
bin hatte ich noch vor heute richtig
viel
Cobblestone abzubauen und zu den anderen
Inseln zu gehen weil dieses Projekt ja
eigentlich nur bis Silvester gehen soll
ich habe diesen Kommentar gelesen
und der kommt also so ein Kommentaren
die Richtung wird schon häufiger
geschrieben dass das Projekt über
Silvester hinausgehen sollen ich wollte
euch beweisen ey wir schaffen es bis
Silvester noch in die Hölle und alles
mögliche aber ich glaube
das Projekt muss länger gehen die
kriegen es nicht hin bis Silvester das
werde ich machen diese Welt will mich
schon wieder komplett verarschen ein
Bogen ist weg
28 Pfeile habe ich nur noch alles
weitere die ganze koppelzone alles auch
weg da oben liegen noch paar Sachen aber
es ist doch echt nicht mehr spaßig
ich dreh doch wirklich durch
ich baue jetzt einfach nur kurz das da
vorne ab ne
damit diese Monster fahren wieder
funktioniert und danach bin ich hier
direkt wieder weg
Alter hey
so alle darunter bitte alle darunter
alle darunter bitte Creeper mir egal
komplett goldhose mir egal alle darunter
bitte
da auch alle darunter lass mich in Ruhe
lassen mich in Ruhe geh da runter komm
geh da runter sehr gut
das hier bauen wir alles ab wenn wir
diese cheatfolge machen wo diese ganzen
komischen Striche in der Landschaft dann
auch endlich mal wegkommen
aber das Ding sollte doch jetzt endlich
mal wieder funktionieren und ich weiß
auch nicht wie hier drauf Sachen spawnen
können weil guckt euch das
ich habe es auf die falsche Höhe gebaut
also man merkt glaube ich wirklich gar
nicht dass ich krank bin
damit wir hier heute zumindest noch mal
so ein bisschen Positivität reinkriegen
und ein bisschen Fortschritt meine Damen
und Herren machen wir noch eben zwei
neue Challenges und zwar 64 Knochenmehl
schon auch auf den challenges dabei
hatten wir zwar schon vorher geschafft
aber ich weiß nicht was ich sonst mit
den Knochen machen soll von daher haben
wir auch 64 Knochenmehl jetzt
hingekriegt aber keine Brot mehr das
heißt ich kann das direkt mal verwenden
hier für ein bisschen
richtig so blöd ne das wäre ja
und dann auch noch von einem Creeper
Eddi verfolgen mich seit Minecraft mit
Luca Staffel 1 einfach nur traurig dann
haben wir genug abgebaut mache ich mir
direkt wieder zu brotten können wir uns
auch direkt eins rein snacken und dann
laufen wir jetzt mal fix rüber zum
Monster fahren am neuen Seide habe ich
ja schon ich brauche tatsächlich noch
drei so dass ich mir ein Bett craften
kann zack zack zack waren irgendwelche
Spinnen aber ich glaube leider nicht das
ist nicht wahr
das ist nicht wahr
dieses Ding ist gerade wieder in die
Luft geflogen Leute was mache ich falsch
ich habe zum Glück jetzt schnell
reagiert und das direkt zugebaut aber
was mache ich falsch zwei Seiten habe
ich jetzt nur bekommen ich brauche noch
ein oh mein Gott ich dachte da kommen
wieder Phantom aber es sind nur
das ist die schlimmste Folge bisher es
ist schön dass ich ein Hühnchen habe das
ist wahrscheinlich auch tot ist
mittlerweile schon ne das ist
wahrscheinlich einfach so gestorben
nein oder
hey das Hühnchen ist wirklich weg
bin ich blöd oder wo ist das Hühnchen
das ist die schlimmste Folge Skyblock
mit Luca bisher meine Damen und Herren
ich hinterfragen gerade das ganze
Projekt noch die Sache ist allerdings
und
oh mein Gott ey das ist doch wirklich
nicht zu fassen
dass wenn da jetzt wieder irgendwas in
die Luft fliegt ne
was soll ich denn machen soll ich damit
Pfeil und Bogen rein schießen oder was
Leute was mache ich falsch mit dieser
Monsterfarm ich meine die funktioniert
unfassbar gut schaut euch mal was da
alles drin hockt
aber ich bin wieder kurz davor dass er
irgendwas explodiert
das ist schon wieder was ich aber gerade
sagen wollte war dass mir es ein
bisschen Hoffnung bereitet dass ich ja
gestorben bin wodurch ich natürlich eine
Menge Level verloren habe aber ich weiß
nicht was sie mir bei Skyblock mit Luca
hier bringen sollen die Sache ist
allerdings dass dadurch erst mal keine
Phantome mehr kommen werden weil ich
gestorben bin und die kommen ja immer
nur wenn man mehrere Nächte am Stück
irgendwie überlebt ich sehe hier vorne
noch keine Seide eingeblendet warum
reagiert er nicht auf diese Creeper hier
so so so
kann man irgendwie machen dass keine
Creeper spawnen guck mal selbst wenn ich
jetzt rumlaufe muss Skelette zack wieder
nur ein Dings habe ich eine Seite bitte
eine Seide keine Seide was sind das eine
Schallplatte
soll ich denn mit einer Schallplatte
während da vorne allerdings hoffentlich
jetzt mal eben kurz noch mal eine Spinne
spawns und dass wir uns zumindest heute
noch im Bett craften können können wir
noch eine weitere Challenge machen und
zwar eine kürbisfarbe nehme einfach
einen kürbispacken in rein kriegen
Kürbiskerne und äh können jetzt
tatsächlich wir haben ein bisschen viel
mit Melonen dann nehmen wir den mal weg
und machen zack
Kürbis fahren
aber gut und wieder ab Sommer meine
Damen und Herren Zack und zack ich meine
es ist schon seit ne wenn man hier so
gegen schlägt und da sind so ganz viele
Creeper und sonstige Idioten die man
hier tötet man kommt auch richtig
schnell an Level aber das braucht man
alles nicht wir brauchen ja nur Seide
und Spinnen kommen ganz ganz selten
leider nur schon wieder Angst dass sie
gleich irgendwas in die Luft fliegt ne
zack ich lauf mal einmal fix rum wenn
noch irgendwas gekommen ist haben wir
Seiden nein oh
64 Pfeile haben wir auch fertig die
Challenge ich werde jetzt auch mal eben
kurz hier vorne nein
nein nein nein nein
nein nein
es ist es ist kein gutes ich brauche
wirklich eure Hilfe Leute
es ist wirklich nicht mehr schön okay
ich werde jetzt so machen ich baue das
jetzt Schritt für Schritt weiter runter
ganz entspannt machen wir das jetzt so
hier vorne
das Abbauen kommen sie dahin erstmal so
jetzt sind sie alle ein Stockwerk tiefer
zack das heißt wir gehen jetzt auch ein
Stockwerk tiefer können jetzt hier
drunter noch eben kurz eine Plattform
setzen Bam Bam Bam Bam und können jetzt
das da drüber auch ganz gediegen abbauen
so dass du noch ein Stockwerk tiefer
runterfallen
was mache ich verdammt noch mal falsch
also ich habe es jetzt so gebaut dass
das hier die Ablage ist wo die ganzen
Monster drauf stehen so dass sie erstmal
nicht hinkommt und wenn ich das jetzt
abbaue sollten von jeder Seite Monster
runterfallen zack damit Creeper da haben
wir die anderen da haben wir die da
vorne haben wir beide
das müssen wir noch hinkriegen
alle tot bitte ohne das was irgendwie in
die Luft fliegt alle sterben nicht in
die Luft fliegen weil dann wäre auch die
Seite weg
ich glaube damit Leute bitte dass ihr
irgendein positives Ende heute noch
haben ich hör schon wieder zwischen
wir haben die Seide wir haben die Seide
oh mein Gott bitte Luca bitte hab jetzt
12 Seite so dass du den Bett machen
kannst
das wäre so ein schöner Abschluss
drei wolle drei wolle jetzt drei Holz
nehmen
drei Holz komm komm komm komm komm es
ist noch möglich
wir haben ein weißes Bett wir haben ein
Bett meine Damen und ich leg mich
einfach hin es ist mir komplett egal wir
können schlafen
zum ersten Mal in Skyblock mit Luca
haben wir eine Nacht übersprungen
moin Leute trymacs hier
ich gebe es auf
ich kündige es jetzt schon mal an in der
nächsten Folge werde ich
ich weiß es nicht
bitte gebt mir Tipps Leute spamt die
Kommentare voll was ist mit dieser
Monsterfarm die macht alles nur noch
schlimmer seitdem ich die habe
lassen Daumen hoch da wenn es euch
vielleicht trotzdem gefallen hat
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen
ich muss ganz dringend in mein Bett